FOR THE COYOTES ACQUIRED FROM
THE TORONTO MAPLE ERIKSSON GOES.
AND NICK RITCHIE.
SHOT.D
>> THAT WAS STANDING RIGHT LET'.
>> BRINGSAS FOUR SHOTS, FOUR OF
THEM ON THE PP THE PLAY.
AND FANS WANT IT ON GOLDEN
KNIGHTS WILL GOT TO BE UP IN TH
FACE OR IT'S GOING TO HAPPENIND
THE BOARDS IT GOES,, ANGLE, AND
GOTTEN A GLOVE ON IT BY WELL.
TWO, OPENING TOOK IT AWAY AND E
THE FACE-OFF.
N
PLAY.
HE THAT WASE CAN'T BUY IT!
REAL NICE PLAYREEN, SHAYNE
GOSTISBEHERE HAS TRIED IT AT
ONE.   IT AGAINST THEVOLVED AS .
>> IT'S PUT AGAINST IT, 2-1
COYOTES!
>> AND IT'S THAT BY THE WAY, I
SCHMALTZ'S 10THS IN, SHOOTS,
STOPS, REBOUND BIG STORY IN THIY
FRONT.  LAT THERE AND
ACTUALLY PEPPERED EARLY AND
OFTEN AS THIS GAMAM
AGAINST THE KNIGHTS.
CARRIER TO THE FRONT A SHOULD D
HERE IS THE PLAY I WAS